the pelicans had missed six of the first
seven shots Anna buritan splashing one
home to the wife her fan derail by
Julius Randle Oliva yours have been done
just observing him really slimming me
tight and fit as Randle is fouled by
Gerald green underneath especially with
all these charter flight what's the big
deal
travel implications used to be one of
the impacts or potential impacts birds
but Bezier looked like a real good lead
they're kind of a combo inside make
yourself available Randall with a
beautiful pass Julius Randle out of the
time on against Jared Dudley with a quad
Kanade contusion
Randle playing strong through the
contact looks like he could have been a
wall offensive foul and then Julius
Randle turned it over again and Tim
Frazier took it away Jim praise your
credit jumping that right on Plumlee
eight-point game
biggest lead so far breeders eyes that
one came with a double-team they came in
these double Yogi's gotta get back out
to yes grub panic laid load for Julius
Randle it's a lot of ball but then it's
lifts off to the wrist and wanting to
play as Randle weights or in traffic
Nikko on the arc to cut it gas down to
six
just giving up too much sighs find a
guard nerds
Randall is over her touch by julius
randle could afford to save it now
Johnson held up by arena's superior pass
beautiful pound sentry Julius Randle and
a nice heads-up play Wesley Ritter up
off the screen
can't waste any time
Julia's going hard to the hole he'll get
it for five point game to 2018 1:13 true
holiday leaving her dog Randall for
three yes still has a two point game
twenty two point four to play got a
Powell
Julius read big tonight our King Ferb
Blair of the game sit five steps back
contested turnovers the 5th for the Pels
Jackson with a run and walked away from
behind Randall got the best up of their
five on for Jackson behind the play so
he's going to pick it up nice pass
Julius Randle I'm not looking for a
strawberry two bigs getting back in
transition that's enough going to do
yeah but your answer your on your your
friends and family Gary Harris
[Applause]
finding some space beautiful thousand
century dolls ever because leave it
again bump eleven ball was passed away
good decision more on the spin mid-range
look at yours two-point game
ten of the shot block over the top great
pass Niko
whatever it takes
it'll be Derek Eubanks got away
don't let it go pop up the trail Julius
at the buzzer yes
great recognition by Randall once again
he's up to 22 and he's keeping the Pels
of the neighborhood talked to me about
it two for two in the third quarter is
Randall from downtown did you get the
stock and now they're gonna their feet
and filling and it'll be Simmons blocked
by Julius Franco yeah why is he going so
hard which is getting loose he said make
sure you go hard all the time
it'll be Julius that was hard to the
whole ball in the body simple play good
breathe good roll good hard roll by
random and put it off his foot got to go
up he knows it too
at the buzzer gets the roll Hellas have
the lead through three we've got 17 lead
changes
the pelicans wasn't the third buy one on
Julius Randall's fade away just in time
drew holiday they want pace there's no
question about that good leave it'll be
Randall Powell's first lead of the game
now Frazier that deep into the shot
block has to make a decision of a spin
good lead and Julius has really made
himself available
good so far you got Randall coming off
with the takes a little while to wear
off rookie and he just puts it right
where he wants to go once he lowers his
hands on his shoulders it's over we'll
give and go what a show it go
totally faked out your michael green pad
but no man's land doesn't get the wall
Randle organic cow's three-on-one it'll
be drew Julius on the finish three-point
shooting last year he's around 30% he's
at 22% right now
shot clock at one fires a bit if he says
I'm not signing that extension your Dell
Demps do you move him at that point and
get as much as you possibly can pretty
pass did get a lot as Anthony Davis
throws it down perfection Randall's top
against kleeberg he'll get it
Kleber walked under and so Randle is
looking for a father he's not going to
get the whistling miss out of a nil
Barnes there takes it away
Wiggins is Randall took it away from
Elmer cake so it was kind of like nails
on a blackboard Randall on the tape
right by towns on the anchor he's going
to the line Lincoln to the three-point
play trying to take a charge Wow
excellent he gets his teammate don't go
and used his right hand to get around
town yes he did it's alive it work and
dumps all over his teammates and nobody
really stood up to him Julius Randle
down with a shot clock coming down gotta
go
he sees him for the last second it'll
work but good recognition late by Julius
get up at the shot clock this have both
of the jumpers and that's a tough one
[Music]
but 88 points with this time you know
some push and shove another turnover and
easiest to for the night for Randall but
that's gonna happen baby's got his 12
for the game now Randall nobody's top of
that freight train he's going to the
line well nobody got back one really
messed up with Randall you look at him
tried to spin it with the right hand
drew finds Julius comes to the line
looking for the three-point play
beautiful the way they time that and
good finish in traffic boy made himself
available
I get more points in the paint but
there's three areas the pelts need to
rip surveying and go to a strong side
sweet sweet sweeping lefty pelicans by
12 their biggest lead of the game
offensive Golden State not enough Randle
will try another three tanks in hoping
right hits the three-pointer off his
first career triple-double he's already
got a 5x5 game and man has he ever grown
in confidence for them take away Julius
Randle off the deflection trying to go
the distance and ATO follow it out first
on that pass Randle getting out in
transition and poise of the paint
basically even and the Pels are so good
now Anthony hurts his hand walks away
and Julia's contested shot well this is
a great block hmm and no disrespect to
to Randle I don't see him as a lob guy
to Holiday becomes the primary scorer he
and Randle will try to carry the load
Randle with a steal the left hander on
the way in and hammers it home Wow and a
very moving chapter of history
and a finish and a foul Randall was a
throw down Watanabe with the foul well
for the pelicans allows them to lead the
lead in paint scores at 58 in with
social media I'm a millennial and I saw
a great picture of you guys on the porch
there at the Lorraine Motel that's a
gimme now drew Holliday waiting for
Randall good position patience it pays
off see
Drew's pace doing that he doesn't get in
a hurry plays at his own pace the
defensive stopper it's a bad matchup
locked away Julia's got a combine good
I'll defense around watching and we'll
come back in Oakland squeals got off of
the paths extra pass waves on the
run-out
Julius gets it 1992 random and shot box
coming down junior season deep trip yes
and an easy takeaway good rotation other
side but Randall take it on this side go
to the live of the Powell for the guy
that gave it away right choice that's
just is that the file you want to take
let's see how they hold up now
do they have a way through let me get
the roll no kept alive by Julius go it's
closed and did they wipe it off
[Applause]
and it's gone long dangerous time for
the pals but the liate plus to play Noah
picked a bad time to blitz didn't ya as
a d6 the citron for pavement handle the
shot clock for Mariana [ __ ] and take it
away Frank Jackson going the distance
how about that our coaching career
started very very early nice play
Randall's getting the steel now but
that's the effort we're talking about in
transition if you want to win that's the
effort you make there's Jackson for
three it's good point gains the joyous
Treves it's a smaller man fees later so
a good idea go to the rim he read it
perfectly
nine point game passing up open shots
here's Randall playing bully ball and he
goes in scores basketball but 13
buoyantly and almost another table
[Applause]
[Music]
deep triple yes julius randle back to
ten
check the extra pass not Julius on the
tape lovely gets it and coast to the
line looking at the three-point Lane and
now the opportunity to get it down to
six
it's just physicality get into his body
you looked helpless got the edge
drew and it capped away now the boom
Frank Gatson inside out top of the shot
clock
Julius settles gets the trip oh man oh
man get some freebies get that number up
get account of the ghost and it will of
the foul and the reach favors move those
feet catalyze Julius he's fouled make a
cow yes he will through the whistle
Julius Randle on continuation to the
strong move towards the defense there
today Davis with a bow 14 of the shot
five for Rubio and ride away favors
couldn't get it
Julia's may attacked it from behind he
was right there
Bank was open to Julius go under the
rock hard big time moved by Terry Stotts
Kevin Hanson talked about a half-time
looking forward to open up I put a call
oh thank you nine plus to play on the
die Julius and it could have been an end
wanted to reach by downshifts they're
led to play though aren't they 61 to 60
he's up to 17 and his pledge buckets now
Julius for three yes back to a two point
deficit nine point four to play on one
point game takeaway Dennis Williams he's
got it you can steal it Julius will
hell's by 15.1 to play timeout Alfred
with another dime heads up look at the
way he saw the ball that's good stuff
but did we always talk about you can't
turn your back on the basketball you can
never lose sight of it and Cameron's
didn't
jaylen Adams right away Alex lens got
length but he's not exactly a back to
the basket guy and that was punched away
by Julius Randle now joyous he's not
giving her doll going hard the whole 14
point man now shot bought considerations
gotta go
Julius sees it he'll take it over Moffat
nerve sized it up pretty well didn't he
em there and trying to find ways to get
around some of the salaries that have
crippled this franchise nice little step
back Julius Randle he was on FBI radio
this morning to Randall Joy's doing
everything he can right he'll put spells
back up by five and Julius is up to 22
and six what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content